attentive so let's I'm not going to do
this for to too long just because this
has been such a long day in total but
let me take a few phone calls because we
had 40 out of 20 website members at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 if people want to start
calling in now here we go thank you for
calling not using your phone have your
question already please hands with my
birthday [ __ ] drama well viewer area to
make sure you're signing up on my
website and all of that normal stuff
because that is all fantastic stuff that
everybody should be doing but we will
take a few phone calls and hear from
some people 6 1 7 I'll just type it into
the chat so people have it 6 1 7 8 3 0 4
7 5 0 and we'll hear from a few people
just to see what's going on let's go
first to our caller from the core 8 0
area code who's calling today from 400
for 8 0 you're on oh it's me that's you
yeah my cantar this is the length of
watching online what's going on the
color still on yeah so my what yes oh my
question is actually I didn't even think
I would get on so I don't have a
question I just want to say I really
enjoyed the debate because it's so
boring to watch it online or on TV yeah
and so alright very good thank you for
the call I really do appreciate it let
me say thanks to anthony ball eos who is
tonight's forty first website member of
the evening stunning stunning evening
can we get
two-fifty before the evening is out
let's go to weirdo let's let's just
check in with Val because she was shot
out of a cannon in the chat earlier hey
Val what's Val from Agawam what's going
on hi David how are you doing good good
good quite an evening I will say it is
and thank you so much for doing this you
do a great job thank you did you notice
that Joe actually called Bernie sort of
referred to Bernie as the president next
to him at one time no I didn't notice
that what was did he say the Kent what
did he mean the senator or a candidate
next to me yes exactly and he started to
say the word president and it was very
odd
there was about like kind of confused
speech from Joe I don't know I mean I
kind of am feeling bad for him in a way
he just seems diminished in some sense I
am I am feeling bad as well I take no
pleasure in in pointing it out it is a
shame it's it's really noticeable and I
don't know why more people aren't
talking about it really yeah I don't
know I mean listen I think that we don't
want to go overboard like there are
clearly concerns there not as big as the
concerns have been with with Trump but
it's like it's something seems to be
going on and it's not good and you know
I don't know now I have to say I don't
know that Bernie I know you're a Bernie
fan I don't know that Bernie did that
well tonight and I know part of it was
just his voice was diminished this
evening at least the first part of the
debate but I think he was hurt by Warren
getting to go first on a bunch of
rebuttals where they had very similar
positions in the end exactly that's
exactly it I kept on thinking can they
just switch it up and just ask Bernie
first for a change because they went
straight to her each time yes I hand I
definitely would Bernie would have
benefited from that rebuttal order being
reversed at least a little bit not to
mention the fact that he has done so
many rallies you could really hear it in
his voice
yeah yeah yeah yeah his voice something
was going on with his voice now
depending on which polls you look at
Bernie
is down 10 took Warren and Burr and
Biden in one poll but then in another
he's in second place right behind Biden
I don't really know what's going on at
this point
yeah I mean I guess time will tell
but hopefully when is the next one
October what October 15 16 I think that
it's back to two nights again 15 16 yeah
well that should be interesting we'll
see what it whittles down to I suppose
it will be yep Val always great to hear
from you
take care David all right we'll see you
Val from Agawam let's go to our caller
from the to10 area code two-one-zero San
Antonio a very very it's like a
tinderbox as an area code for us it
could be good or really really bad hello
yeah two one zero you're on hi David my
name is Fiona I am a very strong Castro
supporter here in Eden or sadena feeding
us like the mermaid
got it yes it's very strong Castro
support but I do understand that if you
don't pull very strong you can't make it
correct so how how how happy would you
because I know you said several times
that you like Castro I've heard you say
that in your show yeah how would you
feel if you were to become vice
president either on a warrant ikut or
maybe even about Bernie ticket listen
he's not the most progressive but I
really respect his depth of knowledge on
the issues that are his issues so like
on policy would he be my favorite for VP
no but he's someone that I I think is
brilliant in a way that a lot of
politicians these days just are not and
you know I wouldn't go rioting in the
streets and anger if who leon castro
ends up being vice president someday una
pregunta mas i
I was the one who asked you if you would
ever interview both from the fifth
column Oh kind youtube yeah yeah I
moderate his discord server and I just
you know put that question out there
because a lot of people want him to do
better and to get a lot of his ideas out
and I know you two aren't exactly on the
same
I think farther left than you are I
thought it'd be a cool idea you guys
throw ideas back and forth it's why I
asked the question all right I will look
into it
hey awesome David yes sir okay Joe all
right there it is see Dana from the San
Antonio area I want to welcome Samuel C
derson which may I mean I don't know if
that's a real name it may be a reference
to Sam cedar and Scott Speer as new
members which gets us to 43 43 new
members a record evening and the people
rejoiced let's go - lets go - Milo who I
have marked in the system as a good
caller Milo don't don't let us now don't
let us down now oh hey David I don't
know I mean I'm increasingly concerned
about burning then he clearly did not
have an incredible tonight tonight you
know I mean obviously he's number one
choice but you know if he is he going
forward like if he doesn't do incredible
and like October yeah you know I
definitely don't think it would be a
horrible idea if you know maybe he would
he could drop out and then you know
because I imagine unless there's polling
to disprove this if Bernie drops out the
overwhelming majority of his supporters
let's go to war and this in depth I'm
not gonna do the entire thing now just
because I did it earlier this week but
what you have to consider is that for
each of these candidates even if a
plurality of their supporters would go
to one candidate or another it's still
only like 20 to 25 percent would be a
plurality and so neither Bernie nor
Warren quitting would actually put
Warren
or Bernie above Biden on the basis of
their second choices according to the
polling I've seen so I think that that's
that's a fault and we wanted we want to
do it let's do away with that notion
yeah yeah yeah I don't know I guess just
like my general sense is like I mean you
know my increasing you know concern
about Bernie is sort of making me wonder
like you know like Warren clearly has
you know more like centrist support so
like you know I don't know I mean it's
more just like based on sort of like no
intuition like I haven't seen an
incredible amount of polling on it yeah
the polling just happened I mean with
this is one case where we want to look
at the data and not intuition I would
say with peace and love and total
respect
yeah yeah right all right Milo Vitt I
you will keep your good caller status so
good connection you got right to the
question Barry but you're scoring a lot
of points thank you very much all right
Milo we will hear from you again let's
go to let's see who else we've got on
the line let's go to James from Long
Island which I don't have you marked
James as a good caller but I do have you
marked as a previous caller let's see
what we can do oh yeah thanks David
I actually got a YouTube video out of my
call once so I think that might qualify
me
oh good caller well with the bad ads for
personal reasons yeah for you converting
me from my time as a conservative so you
were a pro social democracy very good
yes yes I would be programed Bluefield
so my I when I'm watching these debates
I have a very visceral reaction when I
listen to the candidates that have no
shot whatsoever at winning the
nomination like and and obviously it's
good that in a free society that we
should let anybody who wants to run run
yes like they should have that chance
right but at what point are they doing
in actual damage to the discourse that
will lead us to choosing the person who
has the most important job in the world
well we're getting there now so I mean
I'm pulling up the polling right now so
listen it's like right now
you know sestak and Bullock and Delaney
and DeBlasio and Ryan Williamson
Bennett's tire they are all pulling
under 1% and their presence on that
stage
they can't win at this point their
presence is just sort of diffusing the
conversation and a it's
counterproductive we're getting now to
where okay based on the polling
requirements tulsi gabbard wasn't there
and who else wasn't there formula I
don't know who else but the whole point
is I mean it there's a process and I
think at this point if all of those
people were still in the debates it
would be in great part a massive
distraction from people who might
actually have a shot at being the next
president of the United States so I
think that's the whole point of the
process with increasingly strict
guidelines for getting into the debates
of course my personal biases mean that I
think that anybody who's not Bernie
Warren who the judge or yang on the
stage is just a waste of time well on a
polling basis there's no justification
for Biden not being there I mean the
frontrunners are Biden Bernie Ryan and
that's what I mean as Biden to me it's
just I don't think he's fit for the job
anymore
right but of course other people
accounting for my biases he would
absolutely deserve a shot up there but
yesterday like still seeing Klobuchar
are up there yeah she's gotta go I mean
it's it she's basically at the I'm I'm I
don't know if she's already qualified
for the fourth debate but she should
probably be gone by the fourth debate
would be my opinion
all right thanks David all right wait to
hear from you yeah as people in the chat
are saying we're if we're at 43 of 20
website members if we get to 60 I'll
drop acid and call the presidential
candidates and that'll be a real party
let's see let's go to a local caller
let's go to our caller from the six one
seven area code who's calling today from
6 1 7 hey David can you hear me I can
hear you yes indeed cool it's nice to
talk to you guys all right so what I was
wondering is I don't know if you can see
before you know screw me if I'm if I'm
just being if I don't know but yeah you
uh
who would you throw your support behind
maybe it's too early for you to decide
but between me and my father we've
always been talking it's either it's
either Warren or burr because Biden has
[ __ ] brain like under desk gum he's
like EEE I don't think he's that much of
a threat I mean he might be when comes
October but um what do you think uh yeah
I mean my politics are most aligned with
Biden and I'm sorry with Bernie and
Warren and not with uh not with Biden so
yeah those those are the two you know
I'm not like endorsing someone and a
bunch of people have said I shouldn't I
should just talk about who's in line
with my politics at some point I will
tell you who it is I'm voting for in the
primary but Bernie and Warren on policy
are the people I'm most aligned with all
right cool so you but you like you said
you know you support DC uh Bernie
oranges no I did you say don't say that
they are the two that you're leaving
sorry sorry yeah yeah all right well I'm
interesting enough I'm curious to hear
what you say because I know you know
what a TJ Couric has to say I know what
calico he has to say yeah and it's like
I you're the you're the one actually
more to the left than they are so go on
your next caller I think I'm all good
yes sir all right I will take your
advice and I will go right on to the
next caller thank you very very much
let's see we've got so many people
holding let's see if there's any area
code that catches my attention okay well
let's do one more six one seven call and
then we'll get it because that for this
person might have thought I was going to
them with the last one and then we'll go
elsewhere six the next six one seven
caller you're on hey David
this is Adam it's great to talk to you
finally like that so often um so we're
talking about Andrea English that tax
super supporting of that I'm curious
like why exactly wouldn't be because
from my perspective it seems like that
would be the best way to ensure that
companies like Amazon uber Google would
have to pay their fair share like
doesn't seem like there would be a way
around paying that silly things
I don't like the VAT tax as the one of
the first tools I would go to is that
it's relatively regressive because up if
you are in a poorer household more than
likely you're spending a larger portion
of your income just to meet your what we
would call like non luxury consumption
and as a result a poorer household will
end up spending a larger portion of
their income on a value-added tax and so
even if the goal is to say well let's
pull money from these huge corporations
that often pay no taxes then I
understand why it would be appealing but
the ways that I've always seen it I've
not seen exceptions to this that I've
looked at in detail and I would be glad
to is that a VAT tax will have a
regressive effect and I am NOT into
adding new regressive taxes right right
so that the people who would be most
affected would be those who would be
paying more the luxury tax which seems
to be when yang explained that which he
hasn't fully clearly at how it exactly
work but that it would mainly affected
those who are making over certain amount
that would be buying things like Pacific
you can do like buckets or categories of
what you identify as luxury goods but
the thing is you can just do a luxury
goods tax you don't even need to do a
VAT tax more broadly if that's what
you're looking to target understood I
really appreciate you taking my call
right my pleasure great to hear from you
let's go next to the person who has been
holding the absolute longest and that is
our caller from the three-two-three area
code three-two-three what's going on
hello David can hear me yes I can why
not come with us
muy bien okay so I have a question
that's really a question but ever like
honestly what's your opinion this is
yeah let's say there's no written rules
in certain states where people can run
as as a slate of candidates so I want I
don't know
your opinion is on like that I feel like
there's nothing written in stone that
says that candidates can't run I was
late for example Bernie Sanders can know
a point you know or say he's been run
with this vice president look at the
channel you know well beyond before this
suppose that you know faith and when
you're allowed to you know you're
talking about informally right I mean of
course there would be nothing for it but
you're saying right nothing would stop
Bernie from saying I've already decided
that I'm teaming up with so-and-so who's
running for Senate or whatever like some
kind of informal thing in that way right
so on the in the way in that in that
sense that you can have help on your
time can show in the sunset they may be
squeezed from a group that's going to be
you know on the same side of very
similar policies and you can have open
the feel then you know this person can
speak on like issues of like pertaining
to Attorney General and then you know
that could allow you know Bernie to
focus on you know more you know national
security or you know when your country
affairs you know you know are I don't
know if they are written or unwritten
rules about formally saying who would be
your whatever before you're actually in
a position to choose those people but if
you don't say that it you can certainly
say like it could be made pretty evident
who of the people that are campaigning
with you would be likely to be Attorney
General but you know I would say I don't
really know that this matters that much
endorsements typically don't make that
big of a difference and I don't know
that we what you're suggesting would
really be that beneficial I'm willing to
have my mind change but I don't know
that I see it is that beneficial you
don't think that like let's say two
powerhouses team up together like no
potentially like a Bernie Sanders in the
morning I look at Warren I'm sorry
well but that's talking about a running
mate and while they're both candidates
it would be weird for one to say the
other is going to be their VP because
the other one would be like hold on I'm
running for president and then after
that I mean native relatively soon it
would be announced anyway so I don't
know that there's actually that much of
a window of time to do that
I guess I'm guess I'm thinking like in
hindsight I could just people from the
from the get-go like maybe in the next
conventional cycle and listen election
cycle I just don't know that I agree
with you that it would be that
beneficial now let's do this entire
question again in Spanish I'm coming you
from here from a South enough Angeles
and thank you for being wrong very nice
you know that I was the I was out in LA
not that long ago and I went to a an
Indian restaurant called
bod mosh have you heard of it I have not
okay
it was pretty good it was like sort of
Indian tapas I went with there's a
there's a twitch streamer named Stephen
destiny bonel ii I don't know if you're
familiar with him and I had a lovely
dinner with him and his I guess it's his
girlfriend and Hasan [ __ ] it was it was
a crazy it was really a meeting of the
minds oh yeah it's great that you're out
here you know I didn't know that you
actually traveled out here that much
yeah yeah all right man I appreciate the
call thank you we'll talk again soon let
me say thanks to Gary Hall Gary Hall is
new member number 44 of 20 a record
evening it is a magical evening this
evening
let's go next to our caller from see
where do we want to go let's try to one
to I think two is to one to New York
City if I recall correctly hey David hey
hey I just have a quick question about
Yang and Bernie and other somewhat
progressive candidates yes and their
role in the debate so like an earlier
caller was talking about how it seemed
like Warren always kind of got priority
over Bernie tonight you mean and I'm
also yeah I mean - no I mean yeah in the
debate
yep and also it seems like yang never
really good to that much speaking time
to think that this is I guess
intentional by the media outlets you
know a lot of people say that you know
Bernie and yang are always held back by
the media and by the DNC yeah do think
that that has any role in it or is this
just like well so here's the way it
works I mean it's like I understand what
they're doing they're giving more time
to people who are polling higher on the
presumption that these are the people
that the audience wants to hear from and
the the problem is
it only creates a self-reinforcing
feedback loop but I understand why
they're doing it now Burnie typically
has not been suffering in terms of the
amount of time that he's been given but
tonight he seemed to and yeah I mean
like I've talked about this before I
understand why it's being done and you
can make you can make the case both ways
that if you make the debate the time
should be split evenly or you can make
the case that the people who are polling
better should get more time because
that's who people want to hear from but
I think it's more logical that the time
should be divided evenly that being said
it's like it really doesn't make sense
for Amy Klobuchar to get as much time as
the top three because Amy Klobuchar has
no chance so then it becomes maybe there
should just be stricter requirements to
enter the debate fewer candidates on
stage but then they all get the same
amount of time yeah I get what you're
saying but it just seems so weird
tonight we're like I felt like
candidates like Castro or clownfish are
we're talking almost as much as like
Bernie or something then Bernie is doing
I think in some polls better than Boren
and even maybe better than Biden
I don't know that Bernie's willing in
any poll but I think that he is in
second place but yeah I agree that
tonight in particular Bernie's speaking
time was out of sync with what it has
been but I just want to say thank you so
much for taking the call love the show
all right thank you so much for calling
appreciate it let me say thanks to John
Wasel ooh let me I'm gonna get this
right Wasilewski I believe is the way
that it's pronounced and he is new
member number 45 the target was 20 and
we'd absolutely just crushed it we
crushed it like that subscribe button
let's go next to our caller from the
five-one-six-- area code
hey David this is Ben also from New York
hey Jen um so I have kind of like a
two-part question if I don't take all
your time but sure we'll take plenty of
it and I also want to prep it and I also
want to preface this by saying this is
in no way the class on you though it
might seem all right oh good all right
but but I I'm a fan and I like your
constant because you I wanted a few like
objectively speaking people at least
from what I can tell well a lot of like
progressive media are like very like
Bernie Bernie buddy
which is great because I'm a Bernie
supporter too but I also want to hear
you know truth in fact sure so I noticed
a lot of your content is about like
Donald Trump being an idiot most of the
time which you know that's great but cuz
we all hope he's in it
right right so do you think it would be
more beneficial to use your platform to
educate your audience on like the major
differences between like someone like
Bernie Sanders and a little bit more can
i no no sorry I'm also having a very
hard time hearing you
oh no I'm kidding that listen this is a
perfectly reasonable question so I've
dealt with this before here's the thing
we exist in a universe where we're
competing for people's attention there's
a limited amount of time that people are
gonna spend watching shows and so
whenever think of what we're doing in a
day what I'm trying to do is I want to
try to create a balance of stuff that
will do well so we can grow the audience
and get attention and subscribers and
all of this stuff which may not be the
most substantive stuff in terms of like
what is gonna make a difference in the
next 10 years in my life and then use
the audience that we pull in with that
to get them into the more substantive
stuff right how should we be regulating
businesses and what are the substantive
differences on foreign policy between
candidates like you're talking about so
it's a calculation and there's no
question that the the Trump stuff is
low-hanging fruit and we use it in order
to bring people in who have never heard
of the show and then the idea is
brighter in our universe and then we
give them other stuff like our long-form
pieces or interviews or whatever else
that's the idea and we could definitely
say you know what we're only gonna do
the deep stuff but then the audience
would be significantly smaller so we'd
be doing deep stuff but for a much
smaller audience and reaching fewer
people so it's just a calculus that
everybody has to make okay that's fair
and piggybacking off of that for my
second question between Warren and
Sanders I know you say like
ideologically aligned a lot Bernie yep
but
I don't see a lot of I don't see a lot
of progressive media outlets aside from
a few well criticizing wants for some
clear non progressive things that she's
done like voting on Trump's you know
military budget the fact that she did to
support Bernie in 2016 given a choice
yep and just you know recently saying
she's gonna cheat she's okay with a kit
but money like why aren't people talking
about that like she seems like a
half-measure to me you know I don't know
that it's a half-measure I think she's
like an 85 percent measure maybe more
accurate and I don't know who you're
talking about that isn't talking about
that stuff but I've been talking about
that stuff since the very beginning and
I have a clip that did extremely well
about why didn't she just endorsed
Bernie in 2016 and all that yeah you
know we have 20,000 videos but you know
you're you're not wrong I think that
there's one counterpoint to the calculus
which is an interesting one which is
that Elizabeth Warren may be more likely
to actually get more of her ideas done
even if they are less progressive I've
not evaluated that idea fully yet I'm
just kind of mentioning it okay well
that's perfect I appreciate you
answering it and the last thing I was
gonna say is I really enjoyed your
interview with Sam Harris Olympics and
ISM I get sick of his
mischaracterization from other places
like yeah I won't name them but you know
all right I didn't agree with but I
think overall it was a listen it's okay
people sometimes don't agree we got
along perfectly well it was a
conversation he gave 90 minutes of his
time and you know with peace and love we
did it right well I mean you know
there's a ring with somebody and then
they're just calling them you know
Islamophobic just as you don't agree
with them like he didn't do that that
was great right okay David well thank
you for taking my call have a great
night all right very good I appreciate
it thank you so much and that is going
to do it as far as the phone calls go it
has been a very very long night let's do
a raid I hope people will come with me
let's raid let's raid pokey Maine let's
actually do it and see what happens join
me let's see if we can get a reaction
and I'm gonna keep chugging water here
and it's going to be it's going to be an
incredible party and we are almost ready
to do it
only 1300 of you it would be great if
everybody let's all go over there and
take over pokey mains channel and all of
that stuff oh man a lot of people
furious furious with me for all sorts of
different things listen this was a more
than three hour stream and we did
everything we could